so the object is to avoid a tree that's
Roma one and just try to get it all the
way down in this direction so there's
take this it's like a I have to get it
in between us they're like five foot if
you want but that's pretty crafty
no expert birth of the night
you're like you know you live the Caddy
carry my bag I just drink my beer soon
when you win a whole I'll carry the beer
but until you win a whole
you either need to drink less
good stuff
I appreciate the
it's not a good sign when you're winded
I can teach other sounds good that's
true
good it's good to get out of the house
are you kidding me
oh ok actually I can't mail it because
it's going to be too late so I need to
drop physically drop it off to you
O'Malley
hey yo um yo O'Malley stop Mateo nothing
man how you doing my love you can't say
that I've ever been in a roof before
okay and say this is much of a roof to
be what are you doing
hey hey
hey
come on
get out of the [ __ ] car
let's take a seat look good you working
out for something in particular or you
just know what I can't work out just
know you can do whatever you want or
just thinking if it good I thought it
might maybe get something going you get
my phone call I did get your phone call
yeah I'm sorry it's I got a backlog down
there you know you called about you're
going on vacation right what's going on
with the film just just have it out
what's going on what's going on with
film yeah uh yes that's gone what's the
deal with um finishing pumps that the
same as it was a month ago no same was
as it was a year ago actually it's just
the same [ __ ] year after yeah I mean
I can't be the only one that's
passionate about this project I don't
thats not very
a lot of things have been going on you
know I'd saw print of it the other day I
mean your performance is awesome really
is everything that uh it's everything
that I hoped it would be when I cash
another movie just
it's not what I wanted it to be
you're a lazy [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] you know it's [ __ ] what are
you doing what why how I it proved to me
you're just as passion what are yours I
improved to you you just have to be a
little bit more patient yeah so you
leave for two days you come back in two
months from now boom movies done that
seems reasonable to me I I don't have I
don't know how to express this to you
more than I don't have two months I have
two days I don't understand what it is
that makes you say two days two months
before Eve it drafted you have cancer or
you just leave it I when you get back I
don't know I'm not coming back all right
get out of what what's your problem I'm
your [ __ ] neighbor you got nothing to
worry about get the [ __ ] out of the car
right now what the [ __ ] nine prob got
one of that park in your spot or
something no no you didn't park in my
spot you live above me hello welcome to
the [ __ ] world I'm here you're here
you're [ __ ] pissing me off what's the
problem listen what's the problem is
your [ __ ] plan your music every night
past midnight I had a sleepless night
after a [ __ ] hell of oh I'm not gonna
sit here and deal with your [ __ ] I
have somewhere I gotta be yeah exactly
you're in your own [ __ ] world you
don't get it do you I gotta go to a
[ __ ] audition I don't meet these [ __ ]
well you gotta gun it for your [ __ ]
actor now yeah I'm a [ __ ] actor now
oh yeah I'm sure you're a good actor the
[ __ ] do you know about me what do you
know about me bro
you know don't quit your great actor I
wouldn't I wouldn't quit being a good
actors enough I'm just [ __ ] down well
then
it should be man look you know Julie
she's
Julie is filing for divorce
you're getting at the border
that's a hell of an excuse
it's not an excuse me listen I'm sorry
you're getting a divorce but listen
you're getting a divorce is not fun but
at the same time what are you out here
for are you out here to make a film or
fur grows out of your 10 years ago I
made a really see I'm a realist and
apparently you're living in some dream
world that you think you can come out
here and in three months start [ __ ]
acting and start making [ __ ] happen it
takes a long [ __ ] time I will be an
act yeah everybody says that they come
out of here like [ __ ] oh I'm going to
be an actor what's your problem with
that what do you do [ __ ] actor why
are you so negative about acting if
you're an actor should you be a little
more positive maybe if you came upstairs
and we're a little nicer about it we
would see that we maybe have something
in common you know we're both at trying
to be active maybe we can help each
other instead of it
[ __ ] coming out each other like
tunity
wild animals what audition you going to
for a [ __ ] Nike commercial commercial
yeah commercial nike we have baseball
player that's why I'm wearing this VC
get up and about the noise man you know
I'm sorry but
you know there's ways of ask this ways
to ask you to turn it down the choice
tonight
all right well good luck on your
dispatch back for the meet you my right
you can
what did you come out here for man cuz
unless you figure that out no matter
where you go you're gonna be chasing
ghosts men and that's the [ __ ] fat
you're gonna be chasing ghosts cuz if
you don't know what's driving you inside
to get you through things then you're
not gonna figure out [ __ ] want to know
what passion is passions losing things
it's hurt it's ache it's not knowing
when you wake up in the morning how
you're going to go to sleep and in what
condition that's passion passion is what
happens when nothing is happening when
you sit around and wonder why nothing is
happening why nothing is happening for
you why people are leaving you that's
your passion you can quit and you can
walk back and you can say I gave it my
all I give it my seven years but the
passion will still be down there so deep
and you'll feel it every day and you
wonder why did I walk away 17 years plus
one day I could have had
but you won't have it cuz you look
and that's your decision so you can walk
buddy
and I love you and your grid after when
you can walk